Trevor Noah is everything wrong with
late-night he's everything wrong with
politics he is the prepackaged corporate
comedy that they're trying to thrust
upon the American public that people
don't want because they don't think that
he's gonna tip over any carts I want to
talk Trevor Noah a lot of people have
been making these same exact claims out
there where they've just been vilifying
anyone who wants to go back to work as
conspiracy theory nuts as morons as
flyover dunces so let's specifically
just target Trevor Noah because I think
he's everything wrong with not America
because he's not from here and he
shouldn't be here
just humanity was the hb1 for
highly-skilled workers
no no no do you have any somehow he got
in sir somehow someone tricked the
taxman
into thinking Trevor Noah is a highly
skilled worker never saw Letterman I'm
guessing I think you also trick people
into thinking he was funny too well that
was the implication yes so way to lay it
out there yeah well it just in case
somebody misses it so here's the context
I want to run some clips and we'll go
through emblematic of that so it's
perfect because we can rebut all of his
points because it kind of just it's this
amalgam it of horrible points and
strongmen that everyone else has been
making here's a clip I think where the
first clip he's vilifying the protesters
and right here this is the same attack
you hear all the time that people who
are protesting out there right now who
want to restart the economy they clearly
want to increase deaths over the weekend
America surpassed 40,000 confirmed
coronavirus deaths and 750,000 confirmed
infections and because of that most of
us have accepted that as painful as it
is we need to stay at home a little
longer until we can get those numbers
under control but it turns out there's a
different group of people around the
country who are saying nah how can we
get those noses wearing a sweater that
makes him look like he's earning coast
to coast with calls to end stay-at-home
workers found
lining the streets of wisconsin's
rallying cries from Washington to
Colorado to Marilyn actually people just
want it first up it's just so bad if you
had if you make that if you make that
hood pink that's Justin Trudeau and his
little Edmond Dantes like an
uncircumcised Trevor Noah
oh I guess if there's like some
penicillin on that I got a vision in my
head it is remarkable to me that we
vilify these people who want they want
to go back to work by the way and now
we're seeing the numbers increased
suicides increased anxiety depression
why do you want more people to die by
locking them at home yeah this is
something important to know 22 million
Americans filed jobless claims Wow
surveys have showed that one in four
Americans have either lost their job or
had pay cut from shutdowns you have most
businesses they don't even know how much
this is going to last I think was thirty
five percent of retailers that were non
groceries yeah 20-something percent of
hotels 15 to 20 percent of restaurants
they say they'll have to close if the
crisis continues over the coming months
and we know that that kind of stress and
trauma comes with suicide depression
okay that is more of a burden on our
health system than building extra
hospitals that are entirely yeah here's
something else that he talks about he
has this misconception about flattening
the curve and have you noticed by the
way we were always talking about
flattening the curves the whole thing
was the whole thing to hearing that
nearly as much noise flattened occur
flatten occurred you got a flat maker
I've got a flat in the curb kind of
flatten card that's always what we yes
well your think flattening the curve
people need to understand this okay it's
not - you can't eliminate the disease by
flattening the curve it was to manage
the cases in a way so that the
healthcare system wasn't overloaded
right here's the graphic that I think
that we always yeah we would always yeah
and I get it like you just look at the
graph it doesn't really mean anything
you can look into the numbers because
you can make a graph look like anything
but that was the idea you want to flush
and that's a legitimate thing to do I
want to make this very clear that we
should do that we absolutely did do that
by the way okay this is why they said we
need 40,000 ventilators and turned out
they didn't even need 4,000 right they
opened up these new hospitals and now
they're shutting them down they're
laying off or furloughing health care
workers because we have not seen this
influx if people remember it early on
they said hey if you think you have
symptoms and you're young stay home
don't overload the hospital right now at
HuffPo and CNN they're saying young
people are
- long before they flood hospitals yeah
they were converting stadiums into
hospitals they were building hospitals
in Central Park they were doing all
these field hospitals and like ah hell
we built those now we don't need it said
and by the way just something to be
clear flattening the curve is important
so that you obviously give it's that
rubber band effect that you give the
healthcare system enough time to deal
with the burden but as far as the
disease flattening the curve does can
often just make it go longer here's the
thing as long as our healthcare systems
are not overwhelmed flattening the curve
beyond what we have done it's not going
to save lives and it's likely the same
amount of people who will die during the
total duration of the disease right
that's important so this begs the
question this is important like you just
brought up if hospitals are not
overburdened and if you're watching CNN
you may not know this objectively they
are not they're not they've built new
hospitals I don't know that any single
new hospital has had to be used I know
that the vast majority of them we've
reported this in the morning are empty
and they're shutting them down right I
don't know if there's a single one there
prep there probably could be but I don't
know yeah most hospitals extra hospitals
are not being used at all they are not
the hospitals that we currently have are
not at capacity or over capacity so it
begs this question if hospitals are not
overburdened which was the goal of
flattening the curve that means we've
done it what is the goal of a continued
indefinite down you started this with
we've got a flat in the curve okay we've
done it and now you want to excoriate
anyone who says alright we've done it
time to get back to work why I don't
have and I know I'm doing a little bit
of Jesse Ventura might join the Green
Party which sleaze I don't understand
like I'm just asking questions but I'll
give you the answer because they want
this to drag on again they here's the
thing right now if we start the economy
back up and we get back to the best
economy that we've ever had guess what
people are going to remember this oh
yeah them yeah absolutely they wanted
you remember this in November so do I
now they want you to still be in this
come November because there's no
objective reason to try and flatten the
curve when it's already been done
there's no objective reason for an
indefinite shutdown it's absurd by the
way Europe many places in Europe they're
far more leftist they don't have
conservatives know they have liberals
and liberal separatists and communists
and they're like we're gonna [ __ ] on our
economy forever and the next point here
the
we have from Trevor Noah is he makes
this claim you hear this a whole bunch
this idea that people are out there the
more you protest right little view
protest is out I don't know I can't do
the they don't sound like him now it's
hard to do Paxson yes this is this point
that the more that you protest right the
longer we're going to have to lock down
all around the country over the weekend
protests birthing sweater demanding an
immediate end to lock downs and let's be
honest people this is both insane and
counterproductive because the more you
gather in groups the longer the lockdown
will have to go on can you imagine if
during the AIDS crisis mobs of people
gather to gangbang that monkey that
started it all what do we want monkey
sex where do we want it no okay I don't
want I just I only I only the problem I
saw an injured foot and it's gonna be
very difficult for me to to finger with
my toe the trigger to the shotgun in my
mouth yeah it'll be difficult it is so
painfully unfunny and here's the truth
of the matter yours at the yeah okay
obviously there's been some dumb
protesters right a lot of these protests
people are staying in their cars with
plenty of space in between and I've seen
people in their cars with masks which I
we encouraged masks back when the CDC
was saying don't wear masks so you
should be wearing masks so protests when
you're destroying public property good
yeah right that's now bad yeah but it's
now bad and I was you should wear a mask
I think we should dese techni ties masks
in public but if you're wearing a mask
in your car you're so we're talking
about people being in their cars for
example in Lansing cap right let's take
even more extreme it some people on the
beach who are maybe not exactly 6 feet
apart out in the UV light with the salt
water you know that's something that we
need to be upset about people in parks
who are distance none of it compares to
the people in New York who are in the
subways every day they've never been
close Tom they have never been closed it
is why aren't we putting about that and
I understand this because when you live
in a big city you can't be independent
you can't get in your car and drive
anywhere I used to think New York was a
living hell when I live there because I
had to get on the subway I was on the
east side where had to take the green
line and at that point they were talking
about how they were gonna build another
one I think on
well then we were they're gonna build
another one how many might have been on
second they never did they never did it
was a predators been going on for 30
years I think they built it now and I
would have three Subway's go by that
were full where I couldn't get on to to
wait for the next one in New York this
is I can't confine me a place more
contaminated than the El train right
have you seen the Warriors
here's another claim that he made and
you've heard this quite a bit and this
is not new but Trevor Noah makes it
because he doesn't really have he wasn't
a sense for originality doesn't even
enter into the equation oh that the
protests are of course far-right and
some are anti-semitic or something
now these protests have clearly been
infused with a far-right ideology early
many demonstrates his war megawhatts
they held up fancy somatic signs and in
Michigan they even waved confederate
flags a clear symbol of michigan's proud
Southern heritage all right that last
one was a little funny I'll give you
that but let's be really clear here the
sign that said Hale Whitmer that's not
anti-semitic it's comparing Governor
Whitmer to Hitler which I would not
personally do they're trying to imply
that our orders are fascists you know
like they do with Trump all the time and
most importantly it's a pun that works
you should take notes they should give
you a weekend course Trevor Noah and
also you may be you may be known I'm
innocent people out there saying well
what about the swastika that I saw at
these protests yeah
well turns out that was actually an aunt
for supporter pretending to be a trump
supporter and it wasn't even a lockdown
protest at all it was at a Bernie rally
so there is that by the way if you
haven't joined the Mudd Club yet of
course please do use the quarantine
promo code promo code quarantine you get
$30 off that's why we're doing this
month
quarantine month atlatl Peter calm slash
mug club and if you're subscribed on
YouTube you're not convinced to join my
club yet just hit notification bell hit
all notifications so that that way you
you find out about our videos well you
know what it's not that hard weeknights
every night at 8:00 right
congratulations I saved you the horror
of having to making us like I'm sorry
I'm I'm angry today because I had to
spend all morning watching Trevor Noah
well what were you about to say
sometimes with a podcast I guess a lot
more so for the episodes that I'm not on
I listen to it
so I'm out there while I'm being forced
to do worse if you don't want to see my
face Podcast is a good good way to go
yeah here's another claim that he makes
from Trevor Noah is that reopening the
economy is anti-science why because
something something something unfunny
something dr. felching you see often dr.
fauci appeared on the network and made
the case for continuing the shutdown's
fox news the second transition everyone
trusts talk-show host dr. Phil McGraw
appearing on Fox News blasting the
government's response appearing to
downplayed the pandemic okay listen dr.
Phil is not the voice of these protests
now far be it from me to defend dr. Phil
that the plant and this is why they
don't run the press briefings this is
why we did the depress briefing
livestream and we will do it next
Thursday Donald Trump's plan for
reopening the economy it's been created
developed very carefully with a team of
doctors pretending that it's just all
right open fourths a flood that's not
what he's planning you're talking about
a multi-phase system that still involves
mainly social distancing and protecting
our most vulnerable all the way until
phase three if I'm not mistaken they're
gonna be adding more phases which is a
little bit ridiculous to me here's also
by the way what we're talking about
fellas Trevor Noah was she said that we
could reopen the economy soon this isn't
like it's foreign to him the US economy
may be able to start reopening as early
as next month
that's according to dr. Anthony Falchi
the nation's top infectious disease
expert told CNN the economy could
gradually reopen in various parts of the
country depending on the status of the
pandemic widespread testing availability
and sharp declines of people who are
seriously ill we are hoping that at the
end of the month we could look around
and say okay is there any element here
that we can safely and cautiously start
pulling back on if so do it if not then
just continue to hunker down straight
from the freshly shaven Gepetto's mouth
so he's not the only doctor in the world
for summary this is the letter I just
want to cling to doctor foul she dr.
Burks
dr. Burks show dr. Burks
sure doctor we have told people very
clearly in the president guidelines made
it very clear about the expectations of
phase one and remember phase one also
included social distancing and
restaurants social distancing in every
place that was entertainments and
keeping your own individual social
groups to less than ten and we've been
very clear in the guidelines and I think
it's up to the governors and mayor's to
ensure that they're following the best
they can each of those phases to make
sure that both of the public is
completely protected hmm really she's
talking to get about a scale let's let
me give you an analogy let's say that
you have the flu okay
and this is important to note because
you can't only listen to doctor's advice
right you have to listen to economists
you have to listen to people in the
country people who are truckers people
who run small businesses if people who
work in maybe what you determined to be
non-essential services there has to be a
collective discussion so let me kind of
give you let's say you that you have the
flu okay just a really bad flu some year
but you're also have to go through a big
business merger a busy season like for
you - typically in the fall right right
and you have a huge meeting on Monday
that can determine the rest of the year
for your business you absolutely
positively cannot miss do you ask your
doctor whether you can attend that
meeting on Monday you know he's going to
say no right you absolutely know that
the voice of one doctor is not the only
voice it can't be the only voice and
that's the danger with the logical
fallacy of appealing to Authority it's
well doctor Falchi well I can find
another doc right here's another clip
from Trevor Noah where this is another
implication that they're making on the
left you can see this on any mainstream
website or read at politics oh my gosh I
would just love now coup against not
hurt anybody right up now it takes about
conservatives to migrate there and just
just make the voices heard because it is
amazing yeah that's a horrible it makes
me want to you again toe the shotgun
trigger just because I know it's more
effective than a than a 9-millimeter and
we're all about efficiency here so
[Laughter]
protestors are all conspiracy theorists
morons and of course they Darwin award
they deserve to be wiped out side Cove
it now it would be a lot easier to not
take these
protests seriously if they were just
being fueled by Fox News and Internet
conspiracy theories the problem is that
all of these morons also have the
support of The [ __ ] in chief
well luckily for us Sir David
Attenborough has agreed to study these
strange life forms to help the rest of
us understand and here we see natural
selection in its purest form a group of
morons crowded together spitting in each
other's faces as they demand the right
to get a haircut even for the
coronavirus this is too easy alright
here's the thing I like there's an
insurance concern so when I'm not
looking can someone stick a razor blade
in my lunch yeah will that do the Trank
you or they just irritate you well I
don't know hopefully do whatever it
takes okay so the other direction I will
have to baby bear is we do have to go
here's the thing we have senator Ted
Cruz coming up yeah um there's this
first off shows you what he thinks of
everyday Americans right the morons
[ __ ] in chief and it also shows you
what he thinks of his Attenborough
impression for God's sake there are so
many reasons that I can't stand Trevor
no and of course it combines the elitism
this smugness and he by the way he's
probably the least familiar with flyover
country because he just flew to New York
in Los Angeles why would he ever be in
Grand Rapids Michigan why would he ever
be in El Paso Texas he has no exposure
to that so this is not a guy who should
be speaking the average everyday
American good thing is look at his
ratings he's not but there are unfunny
moments for some people for example
Stephen Colbert I don't think it's
always funny but he comes by it honestly
The Colbert Report was very funny when
he used to do it if you look at Jimmy
Kimmel I don't think he's always very
funny but he comes by and honestly the
man show was funny when he was there
with Adam Carolla right if you'll get
David let him and you look at Conan
O'Brien all of these people at some
point even though I don't really like
Jimmy Fallon I understand that college
kids really like his impressions
musically he's gifted I understand it
but not all people Trevor no it's like
he was hit by an unfunny howitzer it is
remarkable to only Trevor Noah and
Samantha P they're smug they hate you
but more importantly when they talk
about Americans wanting to go back to
work and they call them morons while you
subsequently take a check for a job
you do not do as a comedian you don't do
your job Trevor Noah is everything wrong
with late-night he's everything wrong
with politics and he's everything wrong
with this sort of prepackaged you know
they used to call bands like sellouts
yeah unfortunately Green Day they they
committed this this unbelievable
unforgivable sin of having an album that
was successful and I don't really
ridiculous you're a sellout that being
said Trevor Noah
he is the prepackaged corporate comedy
that they're trying to thrust upon the
American public that people don't want
because they don't think that he's gonna
tip over and he carts think about this
for a second you look at the daily this
is why it bothers me he is the least
qualified person for that job he is a
diversity hire if you look at The Daily
Show
it is just a who's who of some of the
best comedic actors and comedians of
arts we have Stephen Colbert
Steve Carell Rob Riggle Rob Corddry who
else do we have
Ed Helms that's right it's it's a huge
list and then you have Samantha bee and
Trevor Noah
and they are the only ones to get their
own shows and you again when taking
scale into account don't watch them
it's everything wrong with the
entertainment industry and more
importantly he's wrong your honor the
South African Defense is wrong you know
what's in here it's just water that's
why they call it acting what it actually
smells garlicky there's something wrong
with the water I think it's going
through the icemaker and we don't have
we don't have the baking soda in the
fridge if you liked this video subscribe
hit notifications or just check back
every single day because we upload a new
video every single day this was actually
taken from the full show a full hour
show the way upload every single
Thursday click that right now go watch
the entire show if you don't want to you
don't you don't have to but if you if
you stop by you know just don't bother
me I'm gonna enjoy my garlic water